welcome to this video playing cosmic
parts that's a new comment right yeah
Brent new account so let's see we get a
modern I Kings Indian maybe c4 neither
three player no let a three-player quite
often play some on place on c4 later
just a more related to the this kind of
with c4 but ok this guy went for set up
with pieces on c3 and c4 yeah I'm
setting up the hippo and in this
particular case with knights on c3 at f3
I think the hippo is quite ok why
doesn't have much much pressure them so
let's see maybe king here they often
even go to a seven with the crew you're
just kind of kind of funky
ok I have no plan anyway so might as
well put the Queen on a seven
yeah this is often the problem yeah okay
here here we go he actually did to
change the pawn structure on is about to
change the pawn structure it looks nice
but then why it has to do something in
terms of structure so what is this um I
can go d5 and c5 looks a bit scary the
bishop on d3 and looks a lot like a
French but okay I have a man at a moment
where it's not so clear how he supports
the center I'd like to after c5 yeah
Bishop d3 I go see five and he really
would like to support the center with c3
with the night is on c3 so that's not
happening I really wonder is it he
cannot go to be three year what that
looks really strange Bishop d3 looks
like the most norman was ever really
know why is hesitating that
okay so let's go this is Bishop d3
cooking on edge services irritating me
quite a bit so let's think just here
right I might take d 5 96 95 85 e6 ugly
huh so do i want to take yeah maybe
maybe take down and then I'd seasick
that could be okay he has to take and
now I'm ready for behalf before okay and
I'm sitting I'm attacking me five quite
a bit so he cannot I think so easily
played at seen 92 or something here we
go so let's go be five
yeah that didn't turn out to be so bad
yeah this thing maybe he had at five at
some moment as possible before Knight b6
then but ok s-sorry 96 and before 94
Queen B 6 is what I was trying to say
not very successfully ok ok I'd say I
change that I'll exchange that very
happily I have suffered my fair share in
French positions so let's get this
mission off take them we are probably
just take them and Lucy eight would be
great to get a night's e52 before would
be nice
yeah so he's going for counter check
them well how exactly am I going to play
love to trade Queens them but not easy
to do I mean f5 I can t key 5 so maybe
let's do this I know his bishop is not
so strong but still it helps to
accelerate my player but damn night on
d7 was was just not very good Oh f5 f5
is now much more dangerous
a stupid ah I totally underestimated
that one I find is super strong once it
hits
okay i have to f5 i have to check with
the bishop somehow can I to cover this
somehow don't know okay let's let's try
to be active
f5 / should be five every six rupee tube
now just rugby to f5 rupee two is good I
mean good I don't know it's what i'm
going to play
f5 look which way if it takes twice on
e6 I can take see two and a half pic
counter counter checks
okay at least the queen is a bit away
now where am I going cannot really cover
this I can actually Queen a it it's not
a bad move it's not so bad time morning
so I've quite some it looks like i have
some pressure there maybe you can still
play a 5 Queen a 7 now that's not
threatening much I have this one temple
that's good that's good check I have to
get you have to enter this position take
them
Jack's a lot good it's remarkable can
take the horn right yeah okay like five
inning on time I didn't even really look
at that yeah that was it wasn't a good
position here I mean maybe maybe I was
just about okay here but yeah it was
when we look at this this should be
quite quite okay oh wow Bishop takes 26
jakey yeah ask the computer and it will
show you what you did wrong blah wyd
wins here Wow hmm yeah that hangs
everything hangs him cool but that's
that's nothing that he should be too
worried about that you didn't see that
one but I know what my mistake was him
this is a night see far they have to
avoid nights if I that's just just bad
just a bad move I was thinking that
would accelerate my play a little bit
dabit it's just a bad idea if I go let's
say here I always have this night
sitting on this this porn so if I this
is difficult to play maybe even g5 is a
possible move to yeah to get this get
this pawn away from the cover
so there went yeah well maybe I'm ok
computer says equal but not after this
f5 was already strong check to phl kingi
need I could have taken d5 his check
didn't see that one ya hear one on time
could have taken if I was checked but ok
I was also not not exactly having much
much on the clock yeah the hippopotamus
is not not brilliant but against this
slowish set up it is it is a playable
opening it's not so bad when the night
silence e303 ok well thanks for watching